please remain seated with your seatbelt
fastened in case of unexpected
turbulence alright cheers Cheers
[Music]
[Music]
I'm sorry did I just say that yeah
things with her aren't romantic anymore
I still in his pants with face I'm
everything so a woman could want I
perform this isn't working out like it's
going on everyone being eminent ball
Jack Harper hub with the guy from the
plane the one he spilled your guts table
had a coincidence casita he's the top
guy at the company everything I said I
wish that I knew what it was like to
have a penis dies with me
I was wondering if you wanted to date
would you want to Hey dating 101 never
let a man know your feelings she could
have any woman yeah but I want you have
this so douchey he's interested in me
and fun and he's funny and because my
car - has he told you anything about
himself no he's a really private person
are you screwing Jack Harper clean up
your desk what you're firing me
you think that your secrets are more
important than mine
no that's not true I don't ever want to
talk to you or see you or hear you or
you were right I should have shared more
with you
men and women should be honest with each
other right from the start he's handsome
he's rich I hate him mr. Harper I'm I'm
Jack Harper Jack you're Jack Harper
[Music]
I give up going to a baby shower
[Music]
you